donc c'est avant tout une provocation
c'est bien évident c'est une provocation
que vouliez-vous montrer et quels objectifs
essayé d'atteindre ces provocateurs
D'abord, elle était complexe et
menées non seulement par les Britanniques mais aussi
Américains parce qu'un Britannique est entré
notre eau là-bas l'après-midi et encore tôt
le matin 730 depuis l'un des aérodromes militaires
L'OTAN en Grèce, plutôt, à mon avis
L'avion de reconnaissance américain a décollé
avion stratégique
il était évident que de moi est sorti et
poursuivre des objectifs militaires en essayant en premier lieu
utilisant un avion de reconnaissance pour ouvrir
actions de nos forces armées sur
coudre sur bordure similaire
provocations regardé où nous avons
tourne sur la façon dont cela fonctionne dans le jeu sont
nous l'avons vu et le savions, donc nous l'avons donné
les informations jugées nécessaires
peut-être que je l'ai laissé filer en incitant les militaires à sonner
c'est la première seconde
c'est juste une chose politique
ce qui s'est passé il y a quelques jours
réunion à Genève
se demander pourquoi il fallait
une telle provocation pour ce que c'est tout
fait pour souligner que
ces gens ne sont pas sans respect pour
le choix des Crimés de rejoindre les Russes
fédération, ils n'y reconnaissent rien, mais
bien ne pas admettre davantage pourquoi
provocations de ce genre mais existent